[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror
so man have i mentioned how much i love
it when i just kind of pick a book
completely at random on kindle unlimited
and it ends up being one of the best
things that i've read all year
if i haven't mentioned that i'm
mentioning it right now uh it just makes
me so so happy to discover a new writer
and something like this good that i
didn't know existed before
now i happen to choose this particular
book from my little list of
recommendations uh just for three
reasons uh the cover is gorgeous
the title actually kind of intrigued me
and i saw like a little blurb next to it
that it had won the ladies of horror
fiction award for best novella of 2020
and i was looking for something a little
bit shorter because i had kind of gotten
behind in my book reading and needed
to read something that wasn't all that
long so i could get a review put up so i
was like ooh best novella i'm here
so the author of this book mona kabani
is a young woman she's uh i believe
she's lebanese uh immigrant she's living
in new york city and though she's
written a couple of novels since then
uh this book the bell chime which came
out in 2020 was her first published work
and that
blows my [ __ ] mind because
the writing in this is just so
i mean it's just so beautifully written
it's so self-assured and it's actually
like really really unsettling like
really really creepy and i can hardly
believe that this was produced by a
first-time author i mean that's just
blows me away
now i would actually suggest going into
this story completely blind as i did
all you need to know about it if you
want to read it
is it's a psychological horror that kind
of uses like night terrors as a jumping
off point
and that it's not told in a linear
fashion but is
nonetheless like pretty easy to follow
and it's also like really easy to get
completely absorbed in even though it's
not hugely hugely long but it's just
like a really
i don't know it's just like a really
immersive experience or at least i found
it that
now if you continue listening to this
video past this sentence some plot
points might be revealed that you don't
want to know it's really really hard to
talk about this book without talking
about some of the stuff that happens in
it i'm not gonna spoil the ending or say
what you know what exactly is going on
and stuff like that but to talk about it
i am gonna have to like reveal some plot
points and as i said i would just
suggest going into this not knowing
anything about it like i did so if
you're not gonna read it uh you know or
if you've already read it and you wanna
go ahead and listen then you can but i'm
just like warning you right now that you
know it's better going into it if you
don't know anything about it and i'm
gonna tell you a little bit about it so
i don't know if i'd actually go so far
as to call the book meta
but it does actually start with the
author have that she's like a forward
and she is describing her own
experiences with night terrors and she
says how a psychologist told her that
one thing that she could do was like set
an alarm for the middle of the night so
that when she has a night terror and the
alarm wakes her up she needs to
immediately write it down
because he's saying well if you keep
doing that then it kind of like takes
their power away
so she says this is where the germ of
the idea for the bell chime came from it
was one of these night terrors that she
woke up in the middle of the night and
like wrote down and actually in the
afterwords she
has like her notes there like what
exactly what had happened in the dream
that she woke up and that she wrote it
down so she does actually tell you at
the end like exactly what it was and
like why it gave her an idea for this
for this story so when we get into the
story proper we're following uh an
initially unnamed woman
now she wakes up at the beginning and
she seems to be
encased in some kind of bag like almost
like a body bag or something like that
and she's laying on a cold metal table
and there's somebody hovering over her
who sort of looks like their head is
deformed
and they're asking her repeatedly if she
can hear the bell chime
now when she says that she can i mean
she's obviously like terrified and it's
really hot she's sweating inside this
bag and everything like that she says
she can hear it and then she's suddenly
subjected to like excruciating pain like
it's like it feels like somebody is kind
of like
burying their arms like into her
ribs and like pulling her ribs apart and
stuff like that like horrible horrible
pain so then she wakes up from what was
presumably a nightmare
she's in her apartment in manhattan and
there's her concerned uh and very very
attractive muscle-bound uh kind of
perfect boyfriend dexter is there
comforting her
so we learned that the protagonist is a
very successful novelist uh in the term
there's kind of like a throwaway thing
later where she gets a phone call and
it's like you know some book deals like
two million dollars something like that
so you know what i mean so so she's like
very successful novelist and her
boyfriend like i said is kind of
seemingly perfect you know he's
beautiful looking it's like he always
smells like roses he's you know he's
totally on her wavelength and knows what
she's thinking all the time and stuff
like that
um so she's got all that going on
but she's also plagued uh quite often by
these terrible nightmares and maybe
we're led to believe is a little bit
mentally fragile because of some
unspoken issues or something that
happened in the past so when she wakes
up it's sunday morning and dexter is
making breakfast but they're out of
bacon you know can't have that so the
protagonist whose name we actually don't
learn until later but is actually lauren
so that's what i'm gonna call her from
now on even though you don't find that
out until later in the book she says oh
i'll just pop down to the little grocery
store across the street to get some
on her way out of the building though
she sees this flyer that somebody has
posted like on the window glass of the
door like from the building like out
into the street
it's a missing person's flyer but the
photo on it is of her but not quite like
it is her
but in the photo she looks like insane
or like demonic
and she's like i never posed for that
picture so where did whoever makes like
where did they get that and she's like i
wouldn't even be able to make my face
look like that if i tried to so she's
like really really unnerved about it
like i said i love stories that start
out with weird [ __ ] like that i mean
that's like such a great
intriguing premise that you're just kind
of like what the [ __ ] like where is this
gonna go like from now on
so she's obviously very freaked out and
she's also really mad because she thinks
somebody's like [ __ ] with her right
so she takes the flyer back into the
apartment and shows dexter her boyfriend
now he doesn't take it all that
seriously um but he does come up with
the somewhat reasonable explanation that
maybe a weird fan of hers or a hater um
maybe put it there as a prank like they
photoshopped a picture of her and and
then put it there like to get under her
skin because like i said in you know in
the context of the story she's
supposedly this big famous writer so she
has like a big fan base so he's like
maybe it was just somebody like that
just to try to like [ __ ] with you so
lauren is somewhat mollified by this but
she's like still pretty unnerved by the
fact she's like look i didn't pose for
that picture and yeah i know photoshop
is a thing but
you know uh that's me and i don't know
how they would have photoshopped me to
like look like that and as the story is
going on she also starts to suspect that
maybe her
you were led to believe her delicate
hold on sanity might be crumbling once
again because it's she says or she
thinks things to the effect of like it's
happening again or something like that
and this suspicion is heightened by the
fact that she's sure that the eyes of
the photo are like moving and like
following her around like they're
watching her
um and she also like later on she throws
the flyer away at one point because it's
freaking her out but it somehow returns
like kind of gets itself out of the
garbage and stuff and what's worse
another one appears where the photo of
her
looks um it's her but it's it looks like
horribly horribly like unutterably sad
like not demonic like the other one and
from that point on lauren starts to hear
this bell chime invading her waking life
like from her dream like can you hear
the bell chime and she starts to see
even more terrible things that may or
may not be hallucinations
at about a quarter of the way through
the story
lauren wakes up inside the bag and on
the metal table from her dream again and
the actual truth of her situation like
starts to become much clearer from there
on out
now as i mentioned the bell chime
jumps back and forth in the timeline and
skates between reality and nightmares
but in spite of all that it remains
completely lucid and very very simple to
follow the entire time i had zero
trouble following what was going on or
anything like that it's very i mean the
clarity is just like is really really
good
so new information gets revealed with
every section and every sort of journey
into the past and into the dream world
and it all in the end it just all comes
together really really seamlessly like
you really get a sense of like what was
happening
now i have seen a couple of reviewers
that compared this story to maybe like
something you'd see on black mirror
and that's a pretty fair comparison i'd
say although
the bell chime is actually set in the
present day and it doesn't really have
any science fiction trappings or any
particular focus on technology so like
in that way it's sort of not like that
but this is really just
purely psychological horror at its
finest and at its most real too i mean
you can really tell just by reading this
that the author has probably experienced
uh many of the frightening emotions and
visions that she describes even if it
was only in her dreams like it comes
across as like very genuine
so the overarching theme of the story
which is very succinctly summed up in
the book's last sentence is what would
you abandon for happiness
and that is definitely a question that
you will probably be asking yourself for
quite a while after you have finished
reading this book this is definitely one
of those stories that is going to stick
with you and is going to like haunt your
thoughts from time to time like as you
kind of go about your life
and i mean the imagery that she was able
to conjure up through her use of
language is like like so vivid and it's
just like really all-encompassing like
all her use of metaphor and some of it's
just like gorgeous
and the way she conveys like the mood
and the emotion i mean just like really
incredible i mean just the way like i
said it's just beautifully beautifully
written it really is very very evocative
so i'm gonna say like uh mona kabani
she's undoubtedly gonna be a writer to
watch in coming years and i'm actually
really excited to read more of her stuff
because this was just exquisite i mean
this was really really good and as far
as i know i think she's written at least
two more novels maybe three uh one of
them is called vanilla a lot of people
had uh uh recommended that one like i
said that was really good so i will
eventually like get around to reading
that as well because i really really
like this a lot i mean it's creepy it's
beautifully written and it was just such
a unique
story that i mean you know it's not
everything's been done but the way that
she came at it was just like really
really unique and i really really dug it
so if you have a kindle unlimited then
you can read it on there for free or
obviously you can uh you can purchase
the paperback if you would rather do
that but yeah i definitely recommend
this one especially if you're really
into like psychological or like
nightmarish kind of i don't i don't
necessarily want to call it surrealistic
but it does have like a nightmarish like
angle to it so yeah definitely recommend
it if you like that kind of thing and
that will do it for this tomes of terror
i will see you guys again on the next
one bye